you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at $887 live where you'll get
honest answers to your Bible questions
let's face it it's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible with 66 books and more than 700
thousand words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
pastor Doug Batchelor president and
Speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact did you know a cold night
on Mars can actually be warmer than a
July evening in the Eastern Antarctica
the new coldest place on earth has now
been measured in the Antarctic Plateau
near the Russian Vostok Research Station
we're back in 1983 they once logged a
record low of a hundred and twenty-eight
degrees below zero but now according to
a paper published in the Geophysical
Research Letters we know that these
frigid temperatures can plunge even
lower people assume the coldest
temperature would be from wind chill on
a mountaintop actually for temperatures
to dip below 130 degrees Fahrenheit
conditions must be ideal the skies must
remain clear calm and dry for at least
four days the chilliest air in the
world's pools will be in these valleys
on the plateau two miles above the sea
and hundreds of miles from the South
Pole fortunately the team of
meteorologists that discovered this
didn't need to venture into Antarctica
on its darkest in those frigid days they
analyzed the data from two NASA
satellites measured against ground
observation they found that over a
hundred times during a 12 year period
they observed temperatures plunged to a
new record low between a hundred and
forty four and a hundred and forty six
degrees below zero did you know that
Jesus said in the last days the
world would experience global cooling
stay with his friends we're gonna learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live you're listening to Bible answers
live honest answers to your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call 888-814-3923 my
name is John Ross and pass the Doug
before we get to the coals this evening
let's stop with prayer dear father in
heaven we thank you once again for the
opportunity to be able to open up your
word and study together and we ask your
blessing upon this program be with the
folks who are listening across the
country and even around the world pray
that you'd guide us loading to a clearer
understanding of the teachings of your
word in Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor that you opened the program
by talking about a very cold place and
hinder fight you mentioned something
about Mars now we know Mars is cold but
to think of a place that could come
pretty close to Mars on earth well
that's quite something yeah a matter of
fact this place there in the Antarctic
Plateau in the Eastern Antarctica it's
colder than Mars because Mars is
something like Earth in that I think
that near the equator of Mars the
warmest that ever gets is like 64
degrees but there are places on Mars
again
you know 50 degrees below zero this has
got temperatures that are like polar
cold are like space cold but you know
there's a verse in the Bible where Jesus
says in Matthew 24 verse 12 speaking of
the last days because lawlessness will
abound the love of many will grow cold
and you can see that in it says you know
evil men and seducers will wax worse and
worse and just the skyrocketing divorce
case and then I teased everyone by
saying that Bible foretells is going to
be global cooling now I'm not saying
that to be political it really does tell
us that after Jesus comes Satan is going
to be cast into a bottomless pit this
world is going to be plunged into
darkness during that 1000 year period
and I expect that when it's in total
darkness during that time before God
makes the new heavens and the new earth
it's gonna be really cold before the
devil goes to the lake of fire he gets
really cold before he gets really hot
and maybe you've not studied this before
friends but before that final day in
Revelation 20 when Satan's cast on the
lake of our fire he is bound for a
thousand years and it's gonna be very
cold during that time we have a free
offer that talks about when Satan will
be bound
tell us about it pastor oz it's a book
that's called Satan enchained and it
talks about this 1000 year time period
you can also read about in the book of
Revelation chapter 20 we'll be happy to
send this book to anybody who calls an
ass again just ask for the book called
Satan in Chains the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and you can ask for that free
gift
Satan each aims again the number is 883
five six seven four seven and you know
pastor that we rather excited to be here
in our new studio for by the lance's
live as you know we've been traveling
for a few weeks and then in the midst of
transitioning over to the new location
but it's kind of exciting to be here I
know we have a number of folks are
watching us on Facebook we want to greet
all of them and I think we're on YouTube
as well so you can tell your friends
about that and a few other places not
quite sure what all the outlets are but
yeah if you do have a Bible question
again we encourage you to give us a call
the phone line here to the
is 804 six three seven two nine seven
with your Bible question and you'll be
able to ask your question here on the
air all right well we're ready to go to
our first caller we have norman
listening from toronto canada norman
welcome to the program hi good evening
pastor doug and pastor john i have a
quick question that with respect to the
great tribulation mentioned in the bible
of the seven years the seven years
before jesus returns right uh-huh and
does that mean that the economy will be
of the time will be worse than the Great
Depression of the 1930s well our first
thing I want to establish is Norman
where do you find in the Bible where it
talks about seven years of tribulation I
I can't quote chapter and verse I think
it's probably in Revelation I am I've
heard of the Great Tribulation many well
there is a Great Tribulation I just want
to make something clear that the the
idea that there's seven years of
tribulation that that is speculation
different churches have different ideas
about how long it will be
and there's two phases of the
tribulation and most churches agree that
there's what they would call a smaller
time of trouble where there's
persecution you can't buy or sell and
then there's a death decree you read in
Revelation 13 during the small time of
trouble you know there's probably going
to be all kinds of economic problems but
we've got to be careful not to think
that we're supposed to wait for an
economic crash and that's gonna mean
that Jesus is coming because Jesus said
something else that catches our
attention
he said just before he returns you know
he said it'll be like it was in the days
of Noah they'll be buying and selling
your building marrying planting sounds
like things are going on in some places
like normal he said in such a day as you
think not the Son of Man comes so we
can't all look for a Nima economic
disaster as the signs that we've entered
the end because the economy is going to
keep they'll still be some economic
activity right up to the end now you
know obviously when the seven plagues
are poured out it's gonna be a disaster
the second half yeah once probation
closes and the seven plagues are poured
out some have wondered will that be a
year will it be a few months I mean you
think about the conditions of the world
when the waters are all blood and the
Sun of scorching men with great heat and
people have annoyed some sore that's
probably a comparatively shorter period
of time the small time of trouble we
don't know exactly how long that will be
it may be few years that's where you're
gonna see all kinds of problems so I
don't know am i answering your question
kind of kind of but it wasn't the answer
I expected but I'm just just wondering
if it's if it's related to economic
problems like we've had since 2008 kind
of thing yeah well right now there was a
terrible economic downturn in 2008 right
now in many places it's just it's
booming and that doesn't make me feel
more secure as far as the times of the
end because you know Jesus said they are
Paul said when they say peace peace then
sudden destruction comes so you know we
need to be ready all the time thank you
for your time pastored all right Thank
You Norman for your patience in your
question the next one that we have is
nap listening from North Carolina Matt
welcome to the program good evening
pastors evening thank you
some clergymen say that if a toddler has
not been baptized and tragically passes
on he's on the road to perdition and
I've heard you say you don't agree with
that and I was wondering what biblical
evidence you have to back up your claim
well it's it's not just my claim the
Bible tells us the criteria for baptism
is that you mean need to be taught it
says that jesus said they should teach
it says you need to believe most
Protestants agree that baptism should be
done for people that are old enough to
understand the criteria repenting of
your sins understanding the gospel
believing the gospel being
hot and discipled it says you know those
are the criteria for baptism babies are
dedicated they're not baptized Jesus was
dedicated as a baby he wasn't baptized
till he was 30 so most Protestants don't
believe in infant baptism if a child
dies before the age of accountability
they're not punished for original sin
that that doesn't say anywhere in the
Bible that they're guilty and they
haven't had a chance to be saved because
they weren't baptized God God does not
save babies based on a ritual I just
don't see anywhere in the Bible
so are these unbaptized babies are they
Heath in or they christen are somewhere
in between well it's neither if Howser
let me let me come at this differently
how was a person judged biblically
according to their works right that's
what Jesus said
everyone's rewarded according to their
works so how is a baby going to be
judged if they're not old enough to know
right or wrong or good or bad or you
know if there's a God or Jesus to turn
to you read in 1st Corinthians 7 that
children of believers there's a
sanctifying influence that the parents
exert over the children just in or
through their decision but they don't
have to know where does it say the child
has to be baptized we should dedicate
our children to the Lord we had a child
dedication this week at our church so
you're saying that godly parents just
parents being godly sanctifies their
children when and you will when you have
believing parents and they have children
if those children should die before the
age of accountability then they're saved
any baby that dies our child dies before
the age of accountability they're
innocent they're not gonna be God's not
going to take them and throw them in a
lake of fire and punish them if they
didn't know right or wrong you know you
have a verse in Matthew Matthew chapter
2 verse 18 it's actually a reference to
an Old Testament verse in Jeremiah 31
where Herod killed all of the baby boys
in Bethlehem and then
Matthew quotes Jeremiah 31 verse 15 that
talks about weeping and Rachel weeping
for her children refusing to be
comforted for her children because they
are no more but then the very next verse
in Jeremiah Jeremiah chapter 31 verse 16
says thus saith the Lord refrain your
voice from weeping your eyes from tears
for your work shall be rewarded says the
Lord and they shall come back from the
land of the enemy so the enemy there is
death there is a promise to the mothers
that their children will be resurrected
they'll come back from the land of the
enemy of course those baby boys are
under the age of accountability so
hopefully that helps a little bit now
you know we do have a book that talks
about baptism baptism is it really
necessary and I think that'd be a good
resource for anybody wanting to learn
more about this and we'll be happy to
send it to those who call and ask the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called baptism is it really necessary
mixed water that we have is Jerry
listening from Oregon Jerry welcome to
the program ah good evening pastors Ross
and Bachelor my question pertains to
church membership let's say if after a
long period of Bible study and prayer
one can find any particular church that
that that he can honestly say he
believes in 100% of the Creed tenants
should should such a person just be
attend and never become a member or what
is your position on that well I think
it's important to people belong to a
church and and be committed in other
words you know you don't want to just
sort of be a hitchhiker in everyone
else's Church at some point you want to
get on board and help carry the load and
and be a member be an active member if
you're waiting until you find a group
that where you can't think of anything
wrong well that may never happen but you
ought to look at the foundational
teachings of a church and and you should
be able to agree with those foundational
what they call the fundamentals and yeah
I do Bible says seek and you'll find it
we actually have a study that talks
about how do you search for a church and
how do you pick a church and I don't
know if you'd be interested we'd be
happy to send you that Jerry well yes
I'll ask for that but basically I
studied with many denominations and when
I when I attend their studies
I can descriptions that they mention are
supportive but they tend to simply
ignore the Scriptures which are not
supportive and that becomes an issue
with me yeah well then you probably
should find a church body that you
believe is as close to the Bible as you
can come and do your best to get it yeah
do your best to get involved if you
don't feel comfortable joining as a
member because there's some something
you feel like you couldn't ethically
support then don't but you know I think
you ought to being part of a church is
important you know the Bible says that
they were baptized and added to the
church and when you become a Christian
you were baptized into Christ into his
body and the church is called the body
of Christ if you'd like to receive that
free book we'll be happy to send it to
you Jerry or anybody who would like to
learn more about finding a church that
actually believes what the Bible says
just call and ask the book is called the
search for the true church gives you a
number of biblical principles that can
be applied in one search for the church
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls an ass that number is
remember that two-thirds of the people
are in vehicles driving as we do the
program for if Joshua had given them
rest he would not have afterwards spoken
of another day now when he says he
speaking of another day you have to go
back to verse 7 where he says David in
one of the Psalms David says today if
you hear his voice and that Psalm 95
verse 7 so Paul is quoting in the book
of Hebrews from David and David says
today if you will hear his voice do not
harden your heart for if josh would
given them rest when joshua brought the
children of israel into egypt I'm
starting to the promised land you need
to know your chronology that David lived
hundreds of years after Joshua said if
Joshua was the one who gave them the
ultimate rest and why is David still
talking about going into the rest in
future tense he said he would not
afterward have spoken of another day
there remains therefore a rest for the
people of God in other words entering
the promised land was not the final rest
for the people of God there was a future
rest that they would find in Jesus of
course the Sabbath's a symbol of that
and he references the Sabbath up a
little higher so he's basically telling
the readers that Christ is the ultimate
rest it wasn't the promised land that
David and Joshua talked about well okay
that's deep does that make sense yeah it
makes complete sense I'm trying to write
it all down because it's very deep
that's awesome well praise the Lord and
I'm trying to think if we have something
on that don't really have a book on that
no not specifically on Hebrews forget
that yeah we get the magazine called the
are the rest of your life yeah yeah
that's a good resource so Carol I don't
know if you've seen that but that is a
magazine that we have an amazing fax
called the rest of your life and we'll
be happy to send that to you or if
anybody would like to read that all
you're left to do is give us a call the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and you can ask for that magazine called
the rest of your life and we'll be happy
to send it out our next corner that we
have is George listening in Louisiana
George welcome to the program
how you doing that pressure you and your
guess we did good all right I've heard
in the past passes and administers even
if Angela said once saved always saved
Oh Bob maybe I will go I'm not gonna
call this ministry an artist pastor's
name and he was preaching on this on
this thing that's saying that's not true
the Bible doesn't teach that matter of
fact the Bible teaches that you may
become sane but you can lose your you
know say the word salvation but you can
be removed out of the book and so the
quick reference verses he gave this
Revelation chapter 3 verse 5 I went over
here and and the journal is writing to
the seven churches
we are the churches I understand in
Revelation chapter 2 verse five and then
you go over to do running-mate chapter
32 and 32 when Moses actually Lord that
Israel had sending a motorcycle Lord to
bottom out of the book and a lot of
motors know who's ever sinned and here's
me here when I'm not allowed to book so
my question is can you lose your
salvation alright well let me give you a
Bible answer on that salvation is a
choice and the Bible says whosoever will
let him take the water of life freely
Joshua said as for me in my house we
will serve the Lord choose you this day
whom you will serve we do not lose our
freedom of choice when we decide to be a
Christian now God will never fail us God
will never let us down Jesus will never
let us go but those verses do not mean
that we lose our freedom to turn our
backs on the Lord so God doesn't
handcuff us to heaven when we come to
Jesus and so there's a number of verses
in the Bible that explained that yes
there are people who walk for the Lord
and they can't still be lost
you've got Balaam was a prophet of God
you've got Judas who walked with Jesus
you've got King Saul who was filled with
the Holy Spirit
and all of them then they became proud
and they grieved the way the Holy Spirit
so a can as a person be lost yes a
matter of fact if any just two weeks ago
I think I preached about that
and so if anyone wants to look at a
YouTube from the Granite Bay Church my
sermon was can the save be lost and and
we want people to have assurance
regarding the relationship with the Lord
but you can't believe that you can never
be the idea you'll never be lost you
know we do have a book that does deal
with this it's a great book a lot of
Scripture it's called can a saved man
choose to be lost and will be everybody
send it to anybody who calls and ask for
George the number is 883 five six seven
four seven again George just asked for
the book or anyone can a saved man
choose to be lost I'll be happy to send
a copy
absolutely next caller that we have is
Kim listening from Wisconsin
Oh cam-cam welcome to the program all
right three well we have just a few
moments before the break yes now I have
a quick question on my study on Isaiah
65 the other day I was studying with the
person and we were going through de bout
the new heaven I believe and we were
reading Isaiah 65 and verse 20 and now
we weren't sure what it means over there
about a child shall die or a hundred
years old but the sin of being and
hundred years old shell be accursed
we wasn't sure what was that about do
you want me to take a crack at that
first of all Isaiah speaking in
beautiful poetic terms here and he's
talking about heaven you're right he is
definitely talking about heaven he says
the voice of weeping will no longer be
heard in her nor the voice of crying no
more shall an infant from there live but
a few days nor an old man that has not
fulfilled his days for the child will
die a hundred years old people what wait
wait wait so children dying in heaven
the word die there also means cease and
it's basically saying a child will not
even cease being a child until it's a
hundred
so it's not talking about children dying
in heaven if you look in Genesis when
God first made Adam and Eve some of
those early characters didn't even get
married until they were over 100 and so
they age more slowly in the new earth
it's gonna be back that way again so and
but it says you know the sinner being
100 years old shall be a curse means
even after a hundred years of sinners
still his name is accursed and that
talks about Daniel 12 the everlasting
condemnation that's on the wicked so no
children are not dying in heaven that's
a rough translation that confuses people
sometimes the child will not die a
hundred years old means the child will
not cease to be a child at a hundred
years old okay so does that make sense
yeah yeah because yeah I think we both
agree no children dying in the new earth
especially at 100 so hey thank you very
much cam we appreciate them we do have a
study guide that talks about heaven
that's right it's called a colossal city
in space because the Bible talks about
the New Jerusalem coming down from God
out of heaven thus the title of the
study guide a colossal city in space
this is free to anyone or you left
today's call and asked the number is 883
five six seven four seven and while you
on the phone speaking with the operator
asking for the free study guide colossal
city in space it's not a bad idea to ask
them about the free correspondence Bible
School program that we have an amazing
fax just a tremendous amount of
resources available to people who sign
up and participate in that
correspondence goal very good well the I
you let's see we've got a minute before
the break we can start a question and
maybe pick it up afterward who do we
have next
all right we've got let's see Phil is
listening from Alabama Phil we have just
a few moments before the break okay um
thank you both for being kind and
gracious to take my call quick question
do the Scriptures make reference after
the flood and then Noah when they came
off the boat as to how we got Egyptians
and Mexicans and Africans and Americans
to show how that they went from being
one race to make it
mostl racist yeah you actually have
reference to how the different races and
tribes sort of fanned out and populated
different parts of the earth but that's
after the Tower of Babel when
everybody's the languages were
confounded people couldn't understand
each other and they kind of grouped
together in families and in groups that
could understand each other God had told
them to go forth and fill the earth they
didn't want to go forth they wanted to
congregate and so this kind of forced
everybody to fan out and populate the
different quarters of the earth and they
then through marrying and remarrying the
people within their various clans
different genetic traits took over and
so it grew into the modern races that we
have in the world today it doesn't
specify if you're not going to find the
word American or Mexican in there but
yeah and gradually the different great
we have again primary races and all the
intermediary a friend you can hear the
music creeping up we're gonna take a
break don't go anywhere we're just gonna
give time for station ID come back with
more Bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing fact
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore comm if you've missed
any of our amazing facts programs visit
our website at amazing facts org there
you'll find an archive of all our
television and radio programs including
amazing facts presents one location so
many possibilities amazing facts org
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 7 to 97 and if
you tuned it along the way this is Bible
answers live a live international
interactive Bible study and so we're
back Pastor Rawson and we're excited to
go back to the phone all right our next
call is calling from New York we have
Elias listening New York New York
Elias welcome to the program Elias Elias
might have his mute on Elias you there
we got let's see deaf now listening from
Texas as a fan nope can't get through
that one
let's try Clayton in New York Clayton
are you there yes I'm here all right we
got one welcome to the program
it's like fishing for a minute there
listen for you for a lot of years you
know well thank you for calling and your
question the question is in the new
earth and a new heaven with Jesus Christ
still have those scars in the sands and
a seat on the side well we're the
processor when I go to heaven I'm
Abraham so-and-so is know like big
enough history I don't think it really a
new world and you have new hell because
we attended there one time all right
well when Jesus rose from the dead and
he had his glorified body did he still
have the scars in his hands yeah and so
I think the only thing that will be a
reminder through eternity of what had
happened here on earth is going to be
the memorial of Jesus love for us in the
scars that he will bear I think through
eternity in saving humanity so yeah I
think yes I I believe he he rose from
the grave with a glorified body yet he
still had the scars I think he'll have
those scars after eternity but that
would be something sad you know yeah I
know there'll be no sadness in heaven or
in Newark but well God will wipe away
all the tears from the eyes but when
when where if we ever see the scars in
Jesus hands it'll just for us be a
reminder of his love and his sacrifice
for us but it'll bring joy when we think
of that there'll be you know the Bible
says the sorrowful or painful memories
will not come into mind and so we're not
going to be in heaven crying after the
Millennium God wipes away all tears from
their eyes
and everything is beautiful then hey
thank you very much appreciate your your
question all right we're going to go to
are you listening in Brooklyn New York
Marty welcome to the program
hiya pestis god bless you and thank you
for taking my call thank you for calling
yes my question I know that the God says
remember the Sabbath to keep it holy and
I've know you've you've answered the
question that the Sabbath is the seventh
day but my question is this myself and
millions of Christians by not practicing
the Sabbath on Saturday are we
committing a sin against God well let's
talk about what does the Bible say sin
is first let me make it very clear there
are going to be people in heaven that
didn't understand different points of
truth they lived up to the light they
had an example would be it's God's plan
for a man to have one wife you probably
agree with that as opposed to two or
three and you know David had at least a
dozen Solomon had hundreds will they be
in heaven
Jacob had four yes because God winked at
their ignorance the Bible tells us in
Acts chapter 17 they'll be people that
maybe kept the wrong day as the Sabbath
and I believe you're gonna see a lot of
people millions in heaven sin is knowing
to do good and not doing it when we know
God's Word and when we know his will and
we say I don't care what God's Word says
I'm gonna do what the crowd is doing
that's when it becomes a dangerous thing
and so it's not just with the Sabbath
truth with with any Bible truth it God
looks on the heart and if a person knows
his will he wants us to do as well so
even though we know it's Saturday and
we're worshiping on Sunday we don't lose
anything by that with God as far as
sinning well ya know if you know if you
know that the Sabbath day is the seventh
day and if you know God says remember
the seventh day and he say that's really
sweet that God said that he commanded it
but everyone else wants to keep the
first day and so I'm gonna do what
everyone else wants to do if a person
knows that and then they say well but I
don't care let me give
verse hebrews chapter 10 verse 26 it
says if we continue to sin willfully
after we've received the knowledge of
the truth there remains no more
sacrifice for sin but a certain fearful
looking forward to of judgment and fiery
indignation now that's not just the
Sabbath but with anything if God has
shown us the truth and we say I don't
care what the Bible says I'm going to do
what what everyone else is doing
that's things most emotion yeah but most
Christians know that the seventh day is
the Sabbath what's a song about millions
of Christians I think some know but they
don't realize that it's a command or
they don't understand that it's one of
the Ten Commandments and it's still to
be kept or some think because pastors
have told them as long as it's a seventh
day it doesn't matter if it's the
seventh day so you know I don't want to
judge anyone's heart God does that
that's one saying we can't I can't tell
you whether a person is saved or loss I
can tell you that when a person knows
something is wrong and they keep doing
it that the Bible says is sin whatever
the category I don't want to just
specify just the Sabbath tree because
you know across the board I think the
Holy Spirit is it's telling me so I know
it is so I guess I'll have to do
something about I just wanted to issue
one would think very alright before you
ask me Marty let me say something jesus
said if you know these things happy are
ye if you do them happy are ye if you do
them all right now you had another
question did the first Christians
worship on Saturday yeah of course yeah
of course they did the it tells us that
when Jesus died on the cross the Bible
says they went home and kept the Sabbath
according to the commandment and that
was Friday afternoon so yeah there's no
question about what the early church
observed so I was
yeah even they would not even finish in
bombing Jesus body because they'd you
know didn't want to disappoint him they
knew the Sabbath was important so yeah I
think it mattered I know quite a few
Christians said of
change selfies well there seems to be a
revival you're right there seems to be a
revival of among a lot of Christians
about that truth and and it's growing
hey you know we have that magazine we
offered earlier called about the rest
and we'll be happy to send you a free
copy of that yes the magazine is called
the rest of your life and we'll be happy
to send that to anyone who calls an ass
and there's a website and there is a
website thank you guys today it is a
great resource it's simply called
Sabbath truth com and we won't encourage
folks to go and take a look at that
there's some video there there is a lot
of Bible study scriptures and stuff you
can read Sabbath truth common I think
everyone who goes they will learn
something when you take a look at that
and it's Cauley is Phillip listening
from Northern California Phillip welcome
to the program Phillip are you there
yes I am can you hear me yes thank you
oh yeah I called before my fingers on
this the thing with divorce and
remarriage I had to go through that I
was always afraid as a Christian I was a
Christian I wouldn't think about
divorcing someone I didn't think
Christians did that but I had a person
the same person divorcing me twice and
then years later I got remarried now I
had reservation but I went and did it
and I did all this research even after I
got married so what's your question why
there's so many different of opinions
about this some people say you have to
divorce your wives go back to your first
when people say divorce your wife stay
Sullivant and some people say continue
on in your christianity and don't ever
do that again well let me give you some
Bible examples cuz that's I think that's
why the Bible is a story book is we can
look at actual life stories and see what
happened Jesus was at the well one day
and he talked to a Samaritan woman
he ended up revealing that he was a
source of living water he was the
Messiah and he said go call your husband
and she said oh I don't have a husband
he said haha you're right you've had
five husbands and the one you're living
with now you're not married to and so
he's still in spite of her scrambled
marital status he revealed to her he was
the Messiah she went and told her count
about Jesus and they came because of her
testimony obviously he forgave her and
gave her a new beginning
even the Samaritans new divorce was not
right and they also new adult adultery
or just living with somebody without
marriage was not right so you know he
God meets people where they're at now if
you're a believer and you don't have
biblical grounds for divorcing your
spouse that's called sin
and God punishes sin you look at what
happened with David and Bathsheba and
they suffered terribly for that after
they suffered you know finally God said
David comforted his wife Bathsheba well
they couldn't resurrect Uriah David
murdered her husband and so he picked
him up where they were and they stayed
married until their dying day but their
relationship began as an adulterous
relationship and they were punished for
it so it's a it's a fearful thing but we
got to be careful not to call divorce
without biblical grounds the
unpardonable sin because the Bible
doesn't say that does that make sense
yeah but a lot of people say survival
summer to that adultery and I've done
really good scared notices you're living
in a continual act of adultery and I
always kind of thought that myself but
that's because I never as a Christian
expecially the life I come out of the
transformation you go through and the
people I've seen chancing murderers turn
into preachers and they've been
preaching for 40 years and that's
typical yeah well I mean God meets
people where they're at hey I tell you
what Philip I've got a book I wrote on
this I think you're gonna really find a
blessing I'll give you a free copy it's
a bigger than regular book it's called
marriage divorce and remarriage and I
wrote the book for people who have
questions just like you and I think
it'll give you some peace and good Bible
answers the number to call for the book
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can just ask for
that book called marriage divorce and
remarriage
I'll be happy to send that out to
anybody who gives us a call and asks a
next hole at the behalf is Paul
listening from let's see New Jersey Paul
welcome to the program good evening
pastors a pleasure to talk to you um my
question is in reference to Isaiah 66
four it says God saw says people will be
destroyed because a
that which I do not delight my question
is if I continue to eat pork shellfish
and things like that do I lose my chance
to inherit the kingdom and eternal life
well if if you I we had a question that
was similar a minute ago about the
Sabbath and my answer is the same if you
know God's will
well let me back up will there be people
in heaven that ate pork and shellfish
yes will there be people in heaven that
deliberately disobeyed God no because
the Lord they didn't surrendered him
when they know God's will as revealed in
his word and they refused to follow
God's will that's called sin now some
people sin unintentionally but when a
person presumptuously says I know I'm
not supposed to take my neighbor's wife
but you know I don't care what I'm going
to do it anyway and I hope you still
save me you know I wouldn't I wouldn't
bet on that person's salvation so it's
not a question of shellfish and pork or
Sabbath or adultery it's a question of
do we are we willing do we love the Lord
if we've accepted him are we willing to
follow what what he's revealed is true
okay and one last question I really love
your guys show and I was just wondering
any chance that would ever be more than
one night a week well you know what they
hope so there are there are there are a
lot of places right now that air the
program we were just in Michigan and
they air the program twice a day you
know a lot of them are reruns
why don't they air the program twice a
day there but you know people can't call
in because their reruns pastor also now
if we did this five days a week
we couldn't travel like we do and do
mission work and evangelistic meetings
and it ties you down five days a week
it's got to be your only job so we
nights excuse me I was going to say do
you have any plans that coming to the
Northeast like New York Jersey and the
metropolitan area oh yeah while I was in
Pennsylvania a few weeks ago I think
there's a good chance that at some point
I'll be back to New York I grew up there
so where do you live to be I'm in New
Jersey Paterson
well we'll forgive you but you can still
come
in New York I wouldn't mind that I
wouldn't mind you have a big following
on the air in this metropolitan area and
I highly recommend it to my friends and
family well we appreciate it we're gonna
come back there we've done meetings in
New York before we'll come back and you
we want to see you on the front row hey
thank you Paul yeah hey we've got a
lesson by the way we're gonna send you
our study guide on God's health plan you
asked the question about pork and it's
in the Bible yes it's a free study guide
all you have to do is call our resource
phone line that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
answer the study guide called God's free
health plan with happy to send it out to
anybody who calls and asks Laurence's
our next call is listening from Virginia
Laurens welcome to the program thank you
Pastor I have a question about heavens I
want to know how many heavens do we have
because when you reach second
Corinthians I think chapter four
Paul talks about cat heaven and I want
to know how many heavens do we have and
which one is being occupied by God and
Jesus Christ
all right good question I think Paul is
actually talking about the third heaven
in is it second Corinthians then the
reason he says that is in Hebrew there
was three words that they used for
heaven there was the first heaven was
the atmosphere around the world where
the birds fly and the clouds float the
air that we breathe that's why it says
the heavens will dissolve with fervent
heat when the Lord comes it means the
atmosphere will burn up the second
heaven is the area where the stars and
the planets are the celestial heavens
that's called the second heaven in
Hebrew mine's the third heaven is the
dwelling place of God where all the
Redeem are going to live God doesn't
have seven heavens that's not in the
Bible even though you got a lot of
sevens in Revelation it never says seven
heavens the people there's some churches
that teach seven heavens and there's
some churches that teach there's
different levels of heaven that
different saved people go to and some
people even teach us segregated heaven
that's not in the Bible in the Bible all
gods
saved are in the same heaven together
it's called the third heaven
that's the dwelling place of God one
more time first heaven atmosphere around
the earth second heaven the Stars space
third heaven dwelling place of God where
the redeemed will be going up when Jesus
comes hey thank you and we do have a
lesson on this subject
we'll be happy I got a book called
heaven is it for real and actually gets
we're talking about what the Bible says
about heaven to receive the book give us
a call the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and just asked for the book
called heaven is it for real
Jameel is our next caller listening from
Michigan
Jameel welcome to the program hello hey
thank you for calling um yes my name is
gmail um so about a little over a year
ago um I gave my mom gave me and my wife
now is them she's my wife gave my life
to the Lord but before that we used to
used to wake up every morning and was
smoked we they call awaken me now we
wake up every morning and we read the
Bible we have devotion that's not to be
better bad life expectantly yeah yeah
God has transformed my life in a major
way
yesterday we we got baptized together
and we dedicated our baby
I don't praise the Lord now what's your
question Jamal yeah well our question is
um what do you how do you answer a
person when they ask questions like um
how do you know that the Bible is the
true Word of God or how do you know that
it's 100% real or hasn't been tampered
with in Janine's and things like that
alright that's a good question first
thing is the Bible contains evidence
that it's a supernatural origin in fact
right now amazing facts is completing a
project we've been working on three
years called kingdoms in time forty
prophecies that prove the Bible and we
go through all these prophecies that
prove the Bible supernatural and so that
you know one of the ways any evangelist
begins a meeting he goes through the
prophecies of Daniel 2 and it convinces
well the Bible is a supernatural book
and then you read the other things that
Jesus said about the Bible Jesus quotes
the Bible as the Word of God Jesus said
thy Word is truth and so when you look
at the testimony of the inspired writers
that said supernatural things they all
look to the Bible as the ultimate Word
of God now if we actually have a free
book on that we can send you and it's
called the ultimate resource Jamal will
be happy to send that to you all you
left to do is just give us a call on our
resource phone line and ask for it
that's called the ultimate resource the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and again after the book called the
ultimate resource we'll be happy to send
that out to anyone who calls and asks
we've got Scott that is listening from
Florida Scott welcome to the program
Doug pesarattu are you tonight great
thank you for calling awesome awesome
I'm the second time cause I just want to
dive right into it I'm very much feel
impressed by the Holy Spirit to go into
other denominations and share the truth
about all 10 commandments but
specifically on Bible study nights
mm-hmm I'm wondering how being you know
knowing the whole truth sometimes I hit
as stepping a block you know when you
get in right a lot of people you know a
lot more than what they're discussing in
it you want to jump right through your
skin sometimes but control yourself not
bear things in a measured way
correct correct what's the easiest way
to other than the obvious like what
you're raising a very important question
you know if if if a believer from one
denomination goes into other
denominations and gets involved in Bible
study to try and share expanded truth or
what they believe some pastors call you
a sheep stealer and then I can
understand that they feel like you're
just instead of going out reaching total
pagans you're just bringing Christians
from one church to another but I think
some doctrines are very important that
the church the Christians are missing
and this is why the Protestant
Reformation happened is Martin Luther
and many Catholics we're not satisfied
that they should just leave Catholics in
darkness about salvation and grace and
so they began to try to teach the truth
in their church and so I don't think
there's anything wrong with going to a
Bible study of another Church and
sharing maybe the expanded understanding
it's been it's been relatively uh a good
positive experience I have no
preordained you know thing going in to
try and steal anybody so I just feel
impressed by the Holy Spirit to do so
you know yeah there's a lot of men and
women they go to men and women Bible
studies that have their
interdenominational and that's a great
format right there because it's just
wide open they all study the Bible
together from all different backgrounds
and you just gotta you know you just got
to share things little by little because
like you say you feel like you're gonna
burst you want to tell them everything
at once but you can feed a person too
much of even the best food and they're
gonna get sick so do it in a little by
little now just Shep I can I can see
that you can relate that sounds like
you're good Kirk thank you Scott
appreciate your call all right you both
have a blessed night thing or a TKO
maybe one more call for a break
yes Sonics full of it behave is seek
listening from Chattanooga Tennessee
Syke welcome to the program hi Zeke I
thank you yeah thank you
listen boys for taking my call my
question is about Exodus chapter 4 verse
24 through 26 or prior to this God just
you know gave notice this mission to
fulfill to go back to Egypt yeah and
then he felt to kill him and then on 26
it says Moses his wife says a bloody
husband our because of the circumcision
circumcision what does that mean I know
if a person's reading along in Exodus
and they come to that they kind of go
what evidently you got to read between
the lines and the best answers I've
heard is that God had called Moses to do
a great work in bringing the people back
to him and out of Egypt he had not
circumcised his own sons even though he
knew he was Jewish
Moses was circumcised because he was
that's how they knew he was a Hebrew
baby when they found him crying there
may have been other ways they knew that
but
he had neglected this very important
command and God had told him to do it
and I think sapore his wife was thinking
it was barbaric and there was a little a
husband-wife disagreement there finally
when he said look we've got to do this
the angel of the Lord is gonna slay me
and she carried out the circumcision and
was kind of a little enraged by it all
you know after that event it appears
that Zipporah and the boys went back to
Jethro and met him later when he came
out of Egypt so that was kind of a
turning point in that story so are you
there does that make sense
but the poor wasn't Jewish
well Sapporo was a Midianite she was the
Bible says she was a Midianite the
Ethiopian that was a term that was used
for just a whole region of southern
Africa in northern Africa
yeah sorry northern Africa Thank You
pastor Rosa from southern Africa of
northern Africa mid south of Egypt and
so and often the what they call the Arab
ah which was the desert that's where we
get the word Arabia and so in one place
it does say that his his brother and
sister were upset because he had married
the Ethiopian we don't know if that
means the pora had died and he married
again it's unclear exactly what's
happening there but yeah so there was
some kind of a showdown there on the
road going to Egypt to redeem the people
they had had a big dispute about whether
or not to circumcise their boys and and
she finally carried it out I hate to
think about that with a chihuahua what
did God salt the kilim know after well
you know of course it can anybody dodge
God if they want to does God ever miss
no no so when it says he sought to kill
him it's just saying that God was he was
facing judgment if he didn't surrender
in that area hey we're gonna run out of
time for this call I hope you understand
thank you very much Zeke for your
question listening friends thank you for
joining us and those who are watching on
Facebook or social media we're glad you
joined us in the new amazing facts
studio for Bible answers live keep in
mind if you've been blessed
by this program we'd love to hear from
you you can go to amazing facts dot
o-r-g let us know you're enjoying it
don't eat online thank you for listening
to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we've built churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and three resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others would you like to know God's
plan for our broken world as revealed in
Bible prophecy
once practical trusted solutions for
your biggest challenges freshly updated
and redesigned amazing facts Bible study
guides provide 27 Bible based topical
lessons with beautiful graphics and
straightforward answers that are
enlightening encouraging and
easy-to-understand each study guide
leads you toward real
Bible answers for the most important
questions in your life how can I have
healthier relationships when and how
will Jesus come again and so much more
don't leave your future to chance
transform your life with truths from the
amazing facts Bible study guides prefer
to watch while you read our brand new
prophecy encounters DVD series makes the
perfect companion set don't wait order
your study guides and DVD set today by
visiting AAF bookstore calm or by
calling 805 38 72 75 if you'd like to
enhance your study of God's Word visit
our website at www.ge.com line bookstore
at AF bookstore calm which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]
you